Speaker 1: Let's go next to Preston from
Maryland. Preston, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hello? Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can. Preston,
you have not called in before, have you?
Speaker 2: I actually did call him once a
while ago during a Trump rally. Oh, okay. My
brain was so turned to mush, I couldn't even.
Think of a question.
Speaker 1: Your brain was mayonnaise
from the rally and you had to hang up on.
Speaker 2: This.
Speaker 1: Primary.
Speaker 2: Good air.
So. So what can we do as the American people to
kind of counter the left? Right. Red team versus
blue team, sort of tribalism that just keeps
getting worse and worse every year, it seems.
Speaker 1: Well, see, the problem with that
question is, I you know, there's there's a couple
how do I even want to approach this? I think
that the degree of tribalism that we have
in the United States is a problem. There
are people who will just support or oppose
ideas based on the letter next to someone's name,
whether it's an R or a D. I think that a lot of
these things are bad. The concern is a lot of
the people talking about tribalism these days
want to sort of portray themselves as the
enlightened centrists who are above partizan
politics and fairly evaluate every issue and
all these different things and want to find
some kind of middle ground when there really is
no reasonable middle ground on so many issues.
There's no middle ground between. Climate change
is real based on the science and climate change is
imaginary. Well, so it's kind of real that that's
crazy. And so my concern is I'm not saying this
about you necessarily president, but sometimes
when people when they just say tribalism is really
the issue. There's a little bit of this, both
sides enlightened centrism stuff going on where
some of these people are nuts. There's no working
with them. They just we need to figure out a way
to get them out of politics.
Speaker 2:
Yeah, I can understand that.
Speaker 1: All right.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Can you. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine. Preston.
Speaker 2: Oh. Oh, yes. So.
Well, you know, that's a pretty
good point. I really have any follow. I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Preston,
we're losing you. So I'm going to let you
go. Preston Very interesting topic. And we've
talked a lot about this enlightened centrism
thing, and it's quite a quite a situation